and Wiz Kalifa Charlie puth is really  really excited to be a first-time Grammy  nominee the see you against singer  earned his first Grammy nomination  Monday morning for his hit collaboration  with Wiz Khalifa the emotional track a  tribute to the late paul walker racked  up three noms including song of the year  et has the exclusive video of charlie  just moments after learning he was  nominated and it's safe to say the 24  year old is over the moon so I just got  back from London just for a day playing  a show and I didn't have cell service on  the plane obviously and I found out when  I landed that  in the end riskily forgot three Grammys  oh my god how insane I'm still Oh what  Charlie's debut album a nine track mine  drops January 29th